- Vielen Dank für die Sachen.
Ich gebe sie dir bald zurück, ja?
- Gerne, Nico.
Die zwei T-Shirts und die Hose
kannst du behalten.
Die Tasche und die Jacke
brauche ich unbedingt zurück.
- Auf jeden Fall. Danke!
- Ja!
Oh, schon 10 Uhr. Ich muss unbedingt
noch etwas für unseren Urlaub einkaufen.
Lisa, was brauchen wir?
Sonnencreme, Saft …
- Wo kaufst du ein?
- Ähm…
Ich kaufe im Supermarkt um die Ecke ein.
- Ja, dann bring doch bitte noch Wasser mit.
- Okay!
- Emma?
- Ja?
- Ich habe ein Geschenk für dich!
- Echt?
- Hm!
- Cool!
Dein Bild!
- Ja, für dich!
- Ich habe auch ein Geschenk für dich.
Hier, ein Notizbuch.
Für alle neuen Wörter auf Deutsch.
Und Seifenblasen!
- Danke, Emma!
- Wo wohnst du jetzt?
- Ich wohne bei Frau Kohlhaas.
Sie ist sehr nett und wohnt
in der Kälberstraße.
- Kälberstraße? Wo ist das?
- Ähm … hier, da!
- Ah, da ist der Friedensplatz.
Da arbeiten Max und Tarek.
Ich arbeite neben dem Theater.
Und die Kälberstraße ist in der Nähe
vom Restaurant und der Sprachschule.
- Und hier ist die Polizeistation.
Hier arbeitet Opa.
Opa!